what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation we are going to watch
today from new rockstar it's been a
while since watching new rockstars vid
this one is not a voss
jess she-hulk episode 1 easter eggs and
breakdown guys subscribe to new
rockstars if you haven't done so already
if you want to watch our she-hulk
reaction that is up here on the chanel
we asked you to leave a like today
anywho let's see what's in store what
did we miss
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm
jessica clements and while boss was busy
falling in love and getting married
congratulations i'll break down the
she-hulk series for you this first
episode is so fun and funny and i didn't
know cousins could be so close i have a
ton of cousins but we hate each other
every time we're together we just fight
one of my closest friends in the world
is my cousin jessica because
all my other cousins can suck it yeah i
want to fight like vos i promise to keep
this business and professional and i
won't bark for she-hulk
let's get into it the marvel studios
title card has not been updated with a
shot of our lady thor from thor 11
thunder oh no
rocket and then they put back on the m
after thor love and thunder by jordan
wearing dragons
from the ten rings we open to a close-up
of jennifer walters giving what at first
feels like her audition tape for
she-hulk but she's actually practicing
her closing argument in her office we
have a little clip right here what is
the responsibility of those with power
do they merely have
an obligation to refrain from the misuse
of that power
or do they have a duty to protect those
without it okay so this opening
perfectly reflects what we'll see
between lawyer jennifer walters just
wanting to be an anonymous lawyer and
she hulk icon superhero public figure
extraordinaire who at times in the
comics has been known to use her name
and presence unjustifiably i mean who
wouldn't you're a hulk as she practices
the camera pans out we slowly get a full
view of jen's very 30 lawyer-like office
she's a busy woman and she works hard
for the
money work hard for them
every type female driven show is already
presenting itself and i stand for it we
see some books barons business law
courtroom 101 her encyclopedias badass
women by rachel walsh and bill o'neil i
suspect that's a picture with their
uncles seeing as the stylized credits we
see a courtroom illustration of her
family at dinner and that man resembles
the bald-headed glasses wearing fellow
we have a bobble head of ruth bader
ginsburg and michelle
ally mcbeal the graduating bear wisdom
class owl along with another little owl
below owls and lawyers have similar
connections they're intelligent wise
efficient they're nocturnal plus they're
just birds of prey so they're recognized
as the animals represent a lot of law
schools and departments yeah yeah deep
symbolism whatever jess ali mcbeal
though dally mcdavid e kelly that's the
big inspiration for the show they've
referenced it at one point i don't care
hear about the owls of gahool nah dudes
store the snyder cut somewhere else i
hear about
about harrison ford's x
yes they're still together they can't be
it's impossible
i would be shocked if they were a ton of
ucla swag along with her two degrees
from ucla we're introduced to our two
colleagues the cheery supportive best
friend nicki ramos played by ginger
gonzaga the paralegal who's basically a
lawyer trainee they provide support to
the lawyers they can interview clients
and witnesses and prepare documents
report they're still very important
folks and underwhelmingly unsupportive
dennis bukowski played by drew matthews
dennis in the comics was the assistant
district attorney alongside jennifer
walters and they both hated each other
he was obnoxious and super annoying i
mean just look at him behind dennis we
get a nice framed photo of the griffith
observatory in los angeles i love that
this takes place in cali let me remind
you behind nicki we get the traditional
brass justice weighing scales which is
completely for gen doing law with no
connection to moon knight consciousness
this is jennifer walters deputy district
attorney on her front door our girl is a
prosecutor with her own office the
deputy district attorneys commonly work
under the district attorney this is also
when nikki mentions jen was hand-picked
to go up against glkh and what we know
from the trailers up until this point is
one glkh stands for goodman lieber
kurtzberg and holloway which is an
homage to martin goodman the founder of
atlas comics that later became marvel
libra for stan lee's real last name and
kurtzberg for jack kirby's formal last
name and holloway who is for holden
holloway the attorney at glkh that hires
she-hulk to be the face of the firm's
new superhero law division and two they
are prosecuting glkh that means this is
probably a test by holding to see jen
aka she-hulk really at work during the
comics holloway offered the job to an
intoxicated she-hulk in a bar but he
always tested her limits and expected a
lot from her he could be testing her
right now with titania there's like a
goddamn sensei in
look at that
there's like
i'm i'm training you to be the ultimate
lawyer jennifer walters when i am done
with you you will have full control over
the law and your spouse we see a second
pair of clothes suit jacket and bottoms
to cover jen in case she hulks out
additionally a lot of lawyers keep extra
clothes at their office for all-nighters
but i'm sure jennifer has also learned
her lesson from ripping out of her
clothes this is when jen breaks the
fourth wall it's so satisfying not only
have we seen similar scenes like this in
fleabag i have to i have to
do that that's my please
deadpool this gag is comedy stage media
gold separating fact from fiction it
shows that they don't take themselves
too seriously but also can give us the
audience much more information my years
in theater and improv have led to this
moment we transitioned to bruce and
jen's trip driving through the woods of
california it's playing money on it by
together pangaea a band based out of
santa clarita california this episode
uses california 30-something year old
regardless but the added music is sort
of an indie cali vibe so a mini bonus we
find out bruce has been able to stay in
human form because he created the device
called the inhibitor though keep in mind
it hasn't fully helped him heal we saw
him wearing in shanxi and head writer
jessica gao has confirmed that this now
takes place a little after shang chi
we've seen variations of the inhibitor
before in captain marvel the cree
created a photon inhibitor to control
captain marvel's cosmic powers and x-men
the inhibitor caller was in days of
future's past also in deadpool 2 they
used the colors to neutralize the
mutant's powers inhibitor simply means
to slow down or prevent a particular
chemical reaction which i believe
ultimately smart hulk is doing to stay
in bruce form inhibitor is the only
thing that keeps john from sleeping with
all of our females that's right i can't
even person i can't even perceive
attraction or you know infatuation and
everybody just looks like a blank blob
face to me like that uh have you ever
seen that episode of black mirror with
jon hamm exactly like that every girl is
just like a scramble head and they can't
talk to me or see me it's horrible and i
hate it
thank you for coming to my ted talk
eating hot cheetos with chopsticks is i
kid you not the only way i'll eat them
and for the same exact reason you don't
want to get it on your fingers also let
us not forget who started this trend
moon night when jim
family bruce retorts though there's
there's also chet at the end we get to
the montage of courtroom illustrations
this one says mom dad aunt uncle and
cousin i assume that chet is the cousin
the uncle is wearing glasses mom and dad
are on the right so that leaves one of
these last women as the aunt this could
be cassandra pike from the comics jen's
aunt on her dad's side she's a biologist
and won a nobel prize for biology she's
also pretty evil in the comics she tries
to kill her brother in niece she-hulk
using her son in this case ched after
giving him injections to become a giant
monster god damn this banner family
unhappy relationship between the two
like us jen has some theories truly
stylish
rogers had sex and win which don't worry
we'll get into because the mid-credit
scene is a doozy we get a glimpse of the
sakara ship we later learn specifically
it's a sakarian class a courier craft a
postman if you will or someone serving a
subpoena to bruce possibly this could be
from the grand master the ship and thor
ragnarok the commodore looked exactly
like this either way this ties to thor
ragnarok and i bet they're looking for
their top tier fighter after stealing
the prize [ __ ] from the grand master or
we could be leading into world war hulk
and scar son of hulk after the
illuminati sent hulk into space away
from earth for being too reckless he
landed on sakaar creating a home there
even finding love and a wife the ship he
arrived on explodes killing his pregnant
wife and a lot of people in the city he
made he goes to earth storms up a bunch
of chaos and kills a ton of folks it's
revealed the child didn't actually die
he emerged from a cocoon scar is super
sick super hardcore but i just don't
think that major scene would be played
out in she-hulk but you let me know what
you guys think in the comments i think
that uh they're setting up a hulk movie
and that we will get our answers
fulfilled not in this show but
in the solo hulk movie
you don't want this to become a hulk
movie in tv show format called somebody
else's name i think it's totally
possible that he has a son he was out
there for a couple of years and we're
finally starting to explore the mature
theme of
interrelations we've been getting a lot
of yellow dollar bill signs and
community guidelines strikes lately so
i'm afraid to say certain words
dumb things i'm like why does this have
a community guideline to each other one
could only assume i feel like he totally
would have a kid but i don't want him to
be scar how he is portrayed in the
comics i want it to be a two-year-old
kid
baby baby hulk
cute and adorable and lovable i don't
want any more of this rage holy crap
yeah merchandise it we're in the comics
she was shot and we got a blood
transfusion from bruce that changed
jennifer to she-hulk this is technically
another type of blood transfusion just
not as thorough this is great to note
how strong bruce's blood is which yes we
already knew but the fact that like most
viruses die on a hint of mass oxygen
this clearly does not and it can impair
someone by a teaspoon's worth they
thought about that brain started acting
weird an incredible hulk or blonsky who
with an already petri dish of other
concoctions turned into abomination
though hulk's blood isn't the be-all
end-all superhero drug the amount of
radiation
as they share the rare genetic factor it
makes sense it would work on her shoot
it maybe works on her mom but don't bet
on any normal civilian every time we get
the sad shot of jen now she hulk outline
reflection on the green crush door and
her silhouette as she backs up and runs
away into the forest like a crazed
werewolf this scene is so funny to me
the transformation scenes in most movies
are she awakens an ideal sports bar very
funny name for a sports car and also a
real sports bar in atlanta no way
and mcu it is a rockstar gas loki during
the storm and the first iron man they
fought near the rocks on corporation
building and agent carter it's revealed
that they created the atomic bomb based
on the formula by howard stark in
she-hulk comics she prosecutes them when
danger man accidentally falls into a bat
of hard atomic water on the job roxan is
a huge powerful petroleum industrial
company and they usually do a lot of
shady stuff in the comics i could
totally see them finally paying off the
whole rocks on side of things by
actually having her go up against uh
corporate one thing that jessica said
was like it's a werewolf transformation
scene and there's another moment that
comes back later into it when bruce is
training her that totally reminds me of
like universal horror movie monster of
what they were sort of spoofing on plus
it's a tribute to werewolf by night
which is coming soon to disney plus i
made that joke in the reaction and i cut
it out of the reaction damn no wonder i
didn't remember it that you made the
joke first i'm just a hack
jen sneaks past the bouncer in the
hallway there's a sign that reads ladies
night when you actually never did that
qr code it takes you to the marvel
website that offers you the first time
free to read along with some special
promotion additionally in the bathroom
there's some lovely graffiti we have the
miss marvel lightning bolt which is
funny oh no way it's placed during 2024
miss marvel takes place sometime in 2025
who pre-drew this and in california no
less possibly someone anticipating the
arrival of miss marvel someone like kang
who we will see in ant-man and was
quantum mechanics kane just going into
women's bathrooms leaving hints stop by
this dive bar and on his way to northern
california and straight up graffiti the
crap out of it we see rest in peace
biggie for big smalls if you don't know
don't stop get it get it used in tons of
songs but i think its origins are by
luke i want to rock i know this because
two live crew remixed it don't listen to
either of your under 18. a little spider
not just spiderman if you sprinkle when
you tinkle be a sweetie wipe the cd and
then the infamous sort of anarchy symbol
infamous 420 with a peace sign and a
zero not a single thanos is right in
sight it's ladies night and what's
ladies night without a bunch of ladies
helping ladies in the bathroom i can't
tell you how many ladies nights i've
been to where it becomes a drunk girls
night out in the bathroom those people
become my best friends immediately just
like these helpful bunch played by
monica garcia bradley tiffany denise
hobbs tony bryce and ariana marie hagan
i love these outland queens and i'm so
happy they're showcasing supportive
women just women helping women we need
that
do we
you know on on second thought probably
not there's enough of that right
you know i think uh men are
usually really competitive with each
other and often get into unnecessary
fist fights yeah or just giving the
wrong look yeah would be really
progressive to show a bunch of men
helping a man out yeah i feel like if
the fate of the universe
lied in a
team's hands it should probably make it
a bunch of men who have to say all men
yeah i think right now what people want
or expecting
is a lot of women to be in superhero
properties and be leading the forefront
so jess what i propose is you subvert
expectations and make it all about men
i'm just saying
trying to explain something
do you want to enlighten you
well actually
she-hulk donned a led zeppelin t-shirt
and i think those are swim trunks we can
assume these are tony's clothes seeing
as tony loved rock and roll the black
sabbath t-shirt and the first time the
answers
soldiers
dc's back in black he listens to ac dc a
lot plus they're on the coast of mexico
at a beach house you need trunks my dude
these little glimpses and reminders will
never be forgotten tear me apart in the
shower
because bruce banner does not like rock
and roll no no no he likes to listen to
classical piano
tributes off of rock and roll songs
as jen walks out to this beautiful rich
beachfront estate we see some little
tony hulk treasures like the iron legion
armordroid helmet from age of ultron i
suspect this is the helmet ultron is
first seen wearing it matches the degree
of damage in the movie they also remove
their mask when the machine laser beam
their eyes so i'm thinking it's just the
junk pieces from that moment behind her
peep the subtle helmet there that's
hulk's helmet he wore in the ring during
ragnarok it's insane
but we'll get back into that in just a
moment we also see a sand hourglass
pretty happy
maybe for the sandy beach
it's definitely the relaxed spot tony
signs bunker is insane this is where
bruce spent the 18 months fixing himself
look at all the stark equipment the
similar gear used to monitor hawkeye and
age of ultron when he was getting new
tissue and the first iron man the gear
behind him when he's asking pep to take
out his heart as vas said in the trailer
breakdown we see the x-ray of jen's
brain we have different vials of jen's
green blood lying around while she was
out he was able to get blood x-rays
literally everything we also see the
schematics of the inhibitor and samples
this low zoom and jen mentioned she's
changed realizing she's a hulk is so fun
and for the visual storytelling enhances
the emotion of the scene and i love when
movies do it like we're creating the
same chaotic realization for both the
character and the audience it's also so
dramatic unnecessarily dramatic
we find out that jen and bruce share a
rare combination of genetic factors so
like i said earlier what would have been
a lethal dose for most was not for jen
jen's blood is slightly different the
way it synthesizes gamma radiation was
able to fully heal bruce's arm when
channeling a distressed emotion jen
offers pixar's inside out the scene
spoiler when bing bong dies he dies okay
it's dramatic who's your friend that
likes to play i can't listen to it we
also see the saw stark industry and
jen's right what psycho has this torture
bunker
for you
this is a funny line
casually how he changes back to bruce
form is by falling out of a plane like
in the first avengers or he gets knocked
out by a robot as tony as hulk buster or
natasha would tell him a lullaby both in
age of ultron hey big guy sun's getting
ready
all these callbacks are worth going back
and watching because i just love them
dialectical behavior therapy is a
psychotherapy that started with treating
personality disorder and interpersonal
conflict in this case definitely being a
hulk and a reminder hulk participated in
yoga to help him in incredible yeah i
just want to say that for those who
don't do any sort of practice for
dialectical behavior therapy highly
attest to it highly attest to it so with
that in mind today's video is sponsored
by headspace they're not paying us jack
[ __ ] today nope and it pisses me off
that they're not
pisses me off yeah but thanks to the
practices of dbt
i can now calm myself instead of getting
enraged and sending an angry email to
headspace for not sponsoring us when
talking about such practices as
meditation and mindfulness i'm no longer
chasing the thought of the rage of not
having a sponsor
he mentions jen reverts back to gen form
when she sleeps which is also what she
did in the comics in very funny ways
like when she wakes up from having men
over and has to revert back before they
notice if stress and high heart rate
changes you into hulk form it would make
sense when you're unconscious you revert
back to your normal self the song plane
is fast motion by my girl sweet tea
she's active in this video sprinting
playing soccer football cheerleading
it's all about the hype and hard work
just like what bruce got jen about to be
doing effortlessly i might add get ready
for these lady pump up jams let's go
through the physical skills he teaches
jen i love their competitive nature but
also that boulder that hulk just tossed
is going to be a meteor to some poor
ship or planet
infamous hulk jump or leap if you will
we've seen it done many times in age of
ultron when he saves natasha or when he
saves tony mid-fall in the first
avengers movie what i love about this
scene is where smart hulk is taking this
seriously jen is like this is easy and
makes fun of him the complete time
balance and yoga which jen is now a
full-fledged pro at this whole ground
pound which to me jim looks much better
at just saying bruce says jen when you
have powers like this it's like putting
a target on your back in the backs of
all the people you care about which is
so true i know she's upset at this point
but in the comics this is how her best
friend died in 1980 run of she-hulk jill
stevens offered to help all the time
when it came to her best friend jennifer
walters at a neighbor's barbecue jen got
a call to come pick up some stuff from
the da's office jill offered to pick it
up instead once she left they realized
it was a trap and unfortunately they cut
jen's break lines in the car and in a
horrible collision jill died jill does
resemble nikki ramos in she-hulk series
but i don't think it's her and i don't
want it to be her but first oh
interesting it might be good don't kill
nicki is making the world's largest
martini and like steve rogers it takes
too much to get these two drunk and cool
you'll always be buzzed but never drunk
i drink to get drunk you guys also this
sounds so expensive is it even worth it
from a later shot there's about 30 empty
bottles yes some are wine bottles but
regardless if each bottle is 20 bucks
give or take that's around six hundred
dollars wasted it's an alcohol being
irritated but this logically just
doesn't make sense and i want them to
stop it's a waste of money whatever kind
of old is a whole pinata perhaps a
souvenir from the celebration of hulk on
the car they had the help you grabbed a
lot on their skulls
we're keeping the car on the back burner
later we see a different angle from the
bar where we see another cut out of hulk
smug hulk am i right we see the initials
bb for bruce barner and ts for tony
stark carved into the bar bruce gets
into the time he spent with tony
creating the bar which was during the
blip and it's sad to reminisce but i
think we're getting into a spot in the
mcu when thinking of tony shouldn't make
you sad he lost him but happy at the
memories they got to make with him a
good time during a hard time which
she-hulk is adjusting to as well we get
the whole thunderclap we last saw him
using this an incredible hulk this move
extinguished fire turned boulders to
robles smacks the crap out of your foes
the thunderclap shockwave destroyed and
it's fun seeing both hulk and she-hulk
using it though she-hulk's feels like a
thunder applause thank you i'll be here
all night jen breaks the fourth wall
again this time as she-hulk but this
time hulk hears her and maybe she'll
start to recognize you can't just do
that anywhere like in fleabag people
notice in fleabag season 2 the priest
interacts with her interacting with the
camera he acknowledges it a lot so
perhaps later down the line we can see
someone close to her recognizing what
she's doing just added fun jen is now
carving her name into the rebuilt bar
and now called bruce's bar the two have
settled down and enjoy their hot cheetos
with chopsticks i think it's cute that
hulk's are party size again his
metabolism is hefty he's always eating
small amounts the tiny tacos in end game
the party size bag of chips just get
this man a damn buffet am i allowed to
curse in this
uh we pan out of the shot
[Music]
i just want to say jessica is you're
doing [ __ ] phenomenal
like this is great top notch i don't
miss eric at all yeah kick him to the
curb who needs them jessica's here to
stay
stay married and in bed with your
beautiful new wife never leave we got
jessica now we don't need you bye boss
voss go on boy get out of here now it's
better than your jessica
she hosts
a new attorney yeah i like that that's
great that's great she host thanks
i'm here all all day
we pan out of the shot from the
courtroom illustrator to see glkh giving
their closing statements to judge price
who we see in the recent trailers and
recognizes being transformed into an
asgardian type elf so if that still
judge price is beyond me right now but
the defendant is played by brandon
hirsch we also get our first look at
holden holloway played by steve coulter
titania is seen busting through the
courtroom played by jamila jamil titina
in the comics has hated she-hulk from
basically the jump because she wins time
and time again one-on-one with she-hulk
but i suspect with the other trailer
footage where we see titania everywhere
she was hired to break through the
courtroom so they could see jennifer
walters change to she-hulk like i said
earlier i think it was all orchestrated
by holden holloway who was a shady
[ __ ] man should i should i try saying
shady man keep the f out you can blur it
we'll bleep it jen punches titanium or
my effort
ready to give her closing statement to a
damn classic by eve who's that girl it's
such a bop basically the song announcing
the queen bee has just arrived and
you're all gonna wonder who she is and
the credits we see about something like
illustration montage one of which is a
board-like presentation by jen to hulk
at bruce's bar piecing together whether
or not captain america is a virgin links
to peggy carter a faceless woman and
then what we can expect as a uso
showgirl and so let's get into this jen
fake drunk gets smart hulk to spill some
beans on steve rogers being a virgin
they even call back to the gorgeous
steve rogers butt did you see that ass
like that ass did not
deserve to diverge it's revealed he does
indeed get down he lost his virginity to
a girl in 1943 on the uso tour now jen's
presentation may lead you to believe it
was a uso dance girl but i think that
she thinks that the unnamed 1940s girl
was either a dancer or a random woman i
think it's laura haddock aka the
autograph seeker and captain america's
person
hey star-lord's mom laura haddock played
meredith quill as well the two roles are
not related at all i don't think
meredith quill was born in 1961 this
girl was a adult by the
40s but come on the scene
definitely hooked up i mean i would
that's everything i spotted in the first
episode of she-hulk follow me on
instagram and twitter at lulu underscore
clemens follow new rockstar subscribe to
new rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye dudes oh my god you were she was
phenomenal dude killing the game great
yeah it was thor and uh she's such a
sweetheart in real life and uh
way nicer than voss in real life oh voss
he's a monster
rude rude man he came up to me he's like
what's up greg and he went to like put
his arms on me and i said whoa dude
permission he first touched you without
asking for your consent jeez
fuss man keep it in your
in your
sleeves and the time before that
saw me across the room he's like greg
and i was like
i'm in the middle of a conversation are
you catcalling me
these are appropriate jokes
intended only for responsible adults who
understand satire
now yes good old satiri yes anyway
guys
follow lulu clemens
follow follow us follow new rockstars
follow somebody you like around in
person before we go we should do it
gabriel
[Music]
gabriel we looked up your name here's
what it
means giver giver meaning
hero
or strong man ooh an l meaning god
you're a strong man god that's so funny
because i just saw a movie recently that
had a character named gabriel and that
gabriel was a dick wow total douchebag
so that's what i heard when i saw you
pledged
i was like
dick who is this douche our patreon
trying to show us love and support he
must be an idiot no man or a woman it
could be a girl's name right could be
gabrielle
oh that's for the two l's and an e it
could well usually but you never know
these days man people try
anyway
look i'm gonna assume that yes you are
these names you are a god you are a hero
you are perfect with the marvel
cinematic universe gabriel we appreciate
you showing your support
being here showing their strong man ways
by pledging money to our patreon that
you probably shouldn't be doing they
should be going
to some
homeless children yes some starving
mexicans in africa yeah you are not
doing it for some reason what is wrong
with you sticking true to your guns
you're staying strong
and you are contributing here
to two people who are are doing
reasonably all right right now
but hey you never know it could all
crumble tomorrow and and we would have
you to thank for catching your name is
god and you know what um they say uh god
doesn't tend to
those who
want he tends to those who deserve so um
i think we're outdoing um
all those people in africa
definitely take that
impoverishing
i don't know why we've
we're scared where's this
it's okay it's okay this isn't for the
thin skinned all right yeah thanks kid
yeah cuz you're a strong man
you